hey guys my name is Jeff it is the 8th
of june and here's the important video
game things up today first sub square
enix have announced a release window for
kingdom hearts HD final chapter prologue
and there's a brand new trailer Peter
feast rides on Kingdom Hearts 2.8 was
first announced in September and
includes a high-definition remake of
Kingdom Hearts dream Drop Distance
Kingdom Hearts cross back cover and
kingdom hearts birth by sleep Oh point
to the trailer shows off new gameplay
from Kingdom Hearts dream Drop Distance
and scenes from Kingdom Hearts cosmic
cover you can check it out in full on
gamespot the game is due out in December
of this year for ps4 next up Square Enix
held their Deus Ex universe pre III
showcase and here's everything that's
coming your way mobile gaming fans can
look for today sex go which will arrive
on smartphones and tablets a few weeks
after mankind divided in fergus in Deus
Ex go you'll employ Adam Jensen's
hacking combat and augmentation skills
to solve puzzles which is supposedly
among the most challenging of the entire
ghosts berries in other day sex move
mankind divided is getting an arcade
like mode called breach which is
described as a connected puzzle shooter
experience and calls for you to acquire
and sell classified corporate data by
infiltrating secure servers each
completed challenge will reward you with
the necessary tools to take on the more
difficult servers and upgrade your
skills and arsenal the mode will include
microtransactions although the dev have
assured you won't need to spend money to
access the full game reach mode will be
available alongside the launch of
mankind divided on august 23 i'm a
slightly different note idols Montreal
has teamed up with robotics start-up
open bionics and hardware manufacturer
razor to create awesome looking days as
inspired prosthetics which will be
available in 2017 finally after a bunch
of pre-announcement leaks watchdogs to
was officially revealed today and who's
we're in sir watch dogs too will be set
in San Francisco and a Jew at on
November 15 your protagonist is Marcus
Holloway and african-american from
Oakland his part of the hacker group
dead sec this is where it starts to feel
a lot like mr. robot as you'll team up
with other hackers and unleash your
skills on a fully trackable game world
Marcus can also use DIY weapons a
quadcopter scout drove a
remote-controlled car and his natural
athleticism to vault over walls and jump
between buildings unlike watchdogs the
first every phone car and machine appear
to be hackable in watch dogs too you
will be able to play cooperatively with
other people and complete quests to gain
followers for dead set you can also play
the entire game in multiplayer Ubisoft
have said the aim is to make the world's
far more vibrant and interesting than
Chicago was in the first game thankfully
for those of us who did play that one
features such as be wildly irritating
driving of watchdogs one have apparently
been addressed and modified for the
sequel let me know down in a comment
section what you think of watchdogs to
and be sure to head to games but we're
we've got stories on Rainbow six speed
banning cheaters and a brand new which
are three update I'll be back with a
bunch of more news tomorrow so be sure
to pop by then